قال رئيس الاعتراف السوري المعارض بان
تركيا اكدت في اجتماع الامس مع وفد
المعارضه السوريه دعمها لقضيه الشعب
السوري والتزامها بدعم الائتلاف والمسار
السياسي واضاف رئيس الالتلاف ان موقف
الحكومه التركيه لم يتغير ولم يتحدث احد
عن التطبيع او مصالحه مع النظام
السوري ان سبيل الخلاص وانقاذ الشعب هو
بخلاصه من هذا النظام
لتركيا موقف كبير مع الشعب السوري منذ
انطلاقه
احتضن التركيه ملايين المهجرين وساندت
السوريين ومؤسساته في كل وقت ولها امنها
وامن شعبها الذي من واجبها ان تحفظه وقد
اكدوا لنا في كل لقاء معهم وقرروا بالامس
دعمهم بقضيه الشعب السوري وعدم التخلي عن
مطالبه
والتزامهم بدعم الائتلاف ومؤسساته ودعم
المسار السياسي حسب القرار 22 54 والعمل
في اطاره لا تغيره في المواقف ولم يتحدث
احد عن تطبيه او المصالحه